It seems indisputable.
I would say that the Canadian healthcare
system is preferable to the American
healthcare system except at the very
highest end and there's a couple of
reasons for that that would even perhaps
appeal to conservatives.
One is the amount of administrative
overhead that spent by Canadian health
institutions as far less in Canada than
it is in the US,
partly because hospitals don't have to
collect money so they don't spend 30
percent of their intake on on the
financial end of the equation,
which is approximately the case in the
u.
s and everyone has access to healthcare
in Canada and because of that,
our rate of individual entrepreneurship
is higher in Canada than it is in the US
and that's because because people don't
have to worry about losing their
healthcare.
If they switched jobs,
they can switch jobs more easily and
they can also take risks if they have a
family that can take entrepreneurial
risks without putting all the health of
their entire family at stake.
So these things can't be broken down
really simply into right wing versus
left wing issues.
Right there.
Too complicated.
But the overall point is that Canada has
done a very good job of having that
conversation even are socialists are
basically fiscally conservative,
right?
Although they're not socially
conservative,
but there,
there,
there are signs of the kind of
polarization in Canada that,
that that's really plaguing the United
States.
And of course that would be,
that's not good for the US.
It's not good for Europe where it's also
happening,
but it's also not good for our country
and I don't want that to happen.
So that's partly why I've been objecting
to the more ill advised in radical moves
that the so called liberals have been
managing over the last few years.